all right thanks for uh
keep watching the
films i'm making
i made now
around 220
youtube films that
you can select from
not all of them are
freely given on the youtube site
i have a patreon site that perhaps you'd
like to subscribe to
and
there you'll see the very detailed films
and the ones that i
if you have nuchi dashi you know and
they come and they live with you
and they're with you for quite some time
like i've had in the past
you'll um you'll give them
more detail finer points
some people call them secrets
and you'll give them this
information freely because
you take them in like a son or daughter
and
yeah you have to be hard with them but
you also give them your gems
so my patreon site i hope
uh i'm giving those students treating
them like uchidashi
and giving them the gems of my thought
this is the turn of a new year 2022
and i've been asked by one of my senior
students
at yondan
if i would um make films
on cytosense's
original
books and this is an introduction
of my thoughts before i start making
them
these films will be available on the
patreon site to the patreon members
and perhaps one day they'll come out on
youtube but
currently that's the only place
that now be listed
i'm going to these are the original
books
and
i will be starting
at volume 3
moving on to 4 and then on to 5.
now why not start the first two
well the first two
are weapons
and there's more than enough weapons
teachers out there
offering their information
and telling you how to do the carters
the suburbs
and there's some very good teachers out
there who have trained an iwama
and so i'm not going to
go down that route on this series so i
should just be sticking to the
three volumes covering the tide in
suicide
i'd like to give you a little bit of
history for those that may not know
about it and then this come from
psychosis his own
mouth what i'm going to tell you
and uh some people may dispute it but
this is i can only tell you what i've
heard
psychosexy decided in 1973
uh to release
these five volumes
the first two being weapons
nothing was said at the time
and not the current doshi but his father
when the third
book was introduced
it was introduced in
japanese and english
and he was asked by the doshu if he
would not make any more books
because at the time
he felt in the early 70s the world
wasn't ready
to know
exact uh
secret the secrets of aikido or the
finer details of like you know
so
as politeness uh sutter said she
accepted yes perhaps the dosha is
correct word may not be ready for it
and let's face it in 1973
that's um
that was very very
new in in the uk
i would go to
a place train in
hillingdon
where what was
known to be
the hut it still is the hut
and that was where
it was known for the
main aikido place to
be
where the japanese used to first come
over kenshiro abbey the big judo master
came over
and he introduced
a mr nakazano
and so on uh sent to narrow and it went
on to other teachers
this has just given you a small piece of
background about
perhaps the world wasn't quite ready
not saying anything a derogative against
the domestic
in nineteen
seventy five
cytosines you thought well
you know we
if we have a burning passion
and something's burning and telling us
that we want to give our senses i get
out of the world
i can sort of understand and knowing
cytosensei that he wanted to give this
to the world
so he made the following two books
and that's why there's five volumes
you'll notice in the first volumes they
were published 1973
and then you would be buying the fourth
and fifth volume in 1975.
and this is the year i bought all all
five volumes plus
there was a cine film a cine what they
call
uh a cine eight or super eight film
on an old cine projector that i
purchased
and i used to watch the films until i
wore them out
over and over and over
when i met saito sensei
uh
10 years late no not 10 years later it
was in 1983 i think it was
he explained to me
that
in a way it was the worst thing he done
by producing these books and letting the
world just buy them
he said because i'm not there
to
instruct them
and
to tell them the finer details
they have taken the books and they've
copied the books because they didn't
have
most people didn't buy the film i
decided to buy the cine films but most
people just bought the books
if you had the books and not the films
you would understand this
perhaps some of you out there
had both like me been doing nearly 50
years now
next year i'll be 50 years so we've been
around a long time
you may have the film
okay so cited since he said how
disappointed he was with everybody's 31
carter
he said why are they doing
this carter with so many errors in it
and he realized what they were doing
was
they were taking the
the books
and
in the thai jitsu
it was easy to follow
in the weapons
i'll just get
one on the volumes
you would see
flying in my frame so i'll just give you
a little close up for anybody who hasn't
seen the books
okay
so
what he hadn't realized at the time was
to make a book you put it in photographs
and you put in a small amount of words
and people were copying the books so
they would go from one
to perhaps another
angle
and because the photos in the book was
cut from
the frames on the film
you might have one frame where sense is
doing the ski part
but the next frame might be five or ten
frames on
and
it might be a block but it doesn't show
you how he actually moved from the ski
to the block
and this is why people
got it so wrong
and he said that they they've
not destroyed the 31 carter but what
he's seeing he was horrified with
so
i wouldn't normally
ever take on trying to explain
psychosenses books
because
to me
i will never ever reach if i lived a bit
would be nice i might reach his level
then
but he was so
knowledgeable
but
my student said the books need
explaining
and so that's what i'm going to do so
this introductory is a bit long
but it's about
trying to
explain while making the films and how
you
instead of
frame by frame now with all this
technology i can talk while i'm doing
the
stages we will have the book and we will
go through each technique and i'll tell
you all the pieces
so that you get it right
if you still these books were still
available i don't know if they are
somebody bought the rights and as we
publish them
they're brilliant books they're
absolutely you know to me they're like
bars of gold to have this information
because
even though they don't have many words
they have very valuable words
but
you're getting one frame in every seven
or one frame and every 10 and because
it's not an equal amount
he's just saying that's a good clip
put that in the book that's a good clip
put that in the book nobody knows how
you go from this
one stage
to the to the next stage if your seven
clicks on or 10 clicks on
you won't know did the hand make a
little movement did it did it drop what
did it do it just shows here the next
scene you know you could be it could be
there but you don't know whether he done
that
to get to there
or
you know or just turned it on the spot
did he make a little
swerve with it
did he drop and make a bigger swirl so
this is what we'll be going through it's
going to take some time
i will do my best i'm only a student of
cytoscency
i'm not a master like he was
um but he did
part with so much knowledge he was a
wonderful teacher for that and i'm going
to try and pass it on to you and hope
that you find it
of pleasure
throughout 2022
okay thank you for time and um if you
wish to subscribe to my patreon site you
can find
the details always below
the screen
thank you